c'était la dernière séance de travail en
groupe aujourd'hui pour les 38
conseillers départementaux d'indre et
loire avant les prochaines élections
ils se sont réunis pour évoquer le
budget une session qui avait des airs
d'adieu pour certains d'entre eux
puisque onze élus ne brigue pas un
nouveau mandat
bilan de six ans de réalisation avec
romain delville
c'est une tradition pour une dernière
session avant élection la séquence
d'autocongratulation des élus qui disent
dépasser les clivages politiques pour
l'intérêt des concitoyens les routes la
fibre optique la gestion des collèges
par exemple ne sont considérés ni de
gauche ni de droite
à l'heure du bilan l'assemblée se veut
consensuel il n'y a jamais eu de budget
avec des voix contre tous les grands
sujets ont été votés pratiquement à
l'unanimité il ya eu écoute qui a eu
respect et la volonté de travailler
ensemble en dépassant des clivages ou
bien d'une sensibilité politique ou bien
urbain rural comme on l'a montré en
votant à l'unanimité pour la création de
tours métropole val de loire pourtant il
s'en est passé des choses d'un point de
vue politique au département la
naissance d'une tendance macro nist la
longue absence pour raisons personnelles
de mounia haddad l'acquisition de
l'ancienne cci où se tenait la session
du jour est bien sûr le décès du
président jean yves couteau en 2016 jean
yves couteau qui le premier parler de
majorité et de complémentarité ce
consensus ne veut pas dire qu'on est
toujours d'accord certains dossiers
d'ailleurs ont fait l'objet d'autres
positions politiques la position
favorable
mais c'est en tout cas une assemblée
dans laquelle tout au long du mandat on
a pu travailler de manière constructive
notamment pour les membres de
l'opposition dont je suis et c'était
particulièrement passionnant de pouvoir
faire évoluer certains dossiers certains
sujets à quelques jours du début de la
campagne officielle
il y à celles et ceux qui partent qui ne
se représente pas 11 au total
et ceux qui se soumettent de nouveau
scrutin la prochaine session sera
électives avec le renouvellement de
l'assemblée
elle se tiendra le 1er juillet jour du
passage du tour de france en touraine
mais avant cela il y aura les élections